nach allem was man hört hat er seine
erkältungssymptome aber ist halt nicht
schwer erkrankt also dass ist scheint
die anfangsphase zu sein und klopfen wir
dreimal auf holz das ist auch nicht
schlimmer wird er ist zu hause ist ein
häuslicher isolation dh darf niemand
anders treffen
man muss unter den eheleuten sparen auch
getrennte toiletten haben sofern denn
dann zwei da sind aber es geht ihm wohl
relativ gut sie wird jetzt regiert also
sprich wer ist der mann der sparen jetzt
vertritt also jens spahn ist nach wie
vor der gesundheitsminister und der
bundesrepublik deutschland hier ein
spannendes jahr vom amt und die
entspannt agiert auch von zu hause aus
also unterschriften machen werden ihnen
hingefahren ansonsten haben wir
videotelefonie und normale telefonie das
ist jetzt alles kein hexenwerk also jens
spahn regiert sein ministerium weiter
oder amtiert weiter als
gesundheitsminister und im haus also für
alle administrativen sachen die hier
gemacht werden müssen oder besprechungen
die anstehen mit mitarbeitern oder in
anderen ministerien
da gibt es ein staatssekretär dr thomas
steffen und das ist echt nummer das ist
ein spitzenbeamter wie wein selten haben
in deutschland der hat früher unter
wolfgang schäuble hat er zum beispiel
die euro-rettung gemanagt also er war
der mann der griechenland einer kurzen
leine gehalten hat er war der mann der
dafür gesorgt hat dass es keine
vergesellschaftung kein keine
verallgemeinerung von schulden gibt also
dass wir nicht alle die schulden dann
hat von griechenland tragen
das war wirklich ein knallharter man als
das finanzministerium einen
sozialdemokraten liegen ist er dann zu
ihren sparten gegangen also der mann
kann was muss kann bange werden
der wichtigste minister erkrankten
mitten in der pandemie was bedeutet das
für das krisenmanagement der regierung
jetzt ja es ist vor allem jetzt nicht so
ein schönes zeichen dass ausgerechnet
bundesgesundheitsminister der erste ist
der in der korona krise auch an cholera
erkrankt weil natürlich kommt da hohen
und hohn und spott auf der da einfach
nicht hingehört der news hingehört wenn
jemand krank wird und es tauchen auch
dann natürlich dann auch die fragen auf
hat sich ausgerechnet der mit der
minister der uns ja allen sagten wir uns
schützen sollen selbst selbst angesteckt
war es im privaten umfeld wo es
passieren kann oder aber hat er selber
oder jemand anderes in seinem umfeld
oder auf einem termin
die regeln also abstand abstand halten
maske und hygiene nicht nicht
eingehalten so also das ist natürlich
ein blödes zeichen dumm gelaufen
wirklich dumm gelaufen politisch ja das
ist die auswirkung die wir momentan
haben aber ansonsten ist es jetzt erst
mal nicht weiter dramatisch
es gab so witzig dass in der stimmung im
land bei den menschen niederschlagen das
hängt glaube ich inzwischen davon ab in
welchem lager man sich inzwischen
verortet hat also die leute die eh nicht
an corinna glauben die
verschwörungstheorie theorien hin
anhängen die nicht glauben oder die halt
nicht glauben dass die das dass die
massnahmen bild begründet sind die werde
jetzt auch sein da sie zweimal ihr alles
hängt euch eine maske ins gesicht bringt
ja gar nichts und ansonsten werden die
anderen die dir halt besorgt sind ich
ziemlich mal zu diesem lager
da steigt der gruseleffekt dann
natürlich ein bisschen mehr weil wenn
selbst den spann trifft der der sie
wirklich da noch geschützt hat dann
heißt das wirklich also jetzt einmal
mehr hände war schon einmal mehr die
maske auf lasst uns mal auf die stimmung
im land überhaupt zu sprechen kommen es
gibt eine neue studie wir haben es dann
wieder das klopapier geht aus es scheint
ein bisschen so als wären wir alle ein
bisschen corona müde wie geplant die
politik darauf jetzt zu reagieren wie
will man das auffangen
es gibt ja diese bizarre klopapier
garantie von der bundesregierung also in
der finanzkrise wurde uns versprochen
dass unser erspartes sicher ist jetzt in
der korona krise ist unter klopapier
sicher na hallo
aber die politik muss die politik kann
darauf nur reagieren mit beruhigenden
worten besänftigen worten versuchen den
leuten jetzt die angst zu nehmen und die
panik zu nehmen sagen leute klopapier
ist genug da auf der welt daran werden
wir jetzt nicht zugrunde gehen und
hamsterkäufe also ist es immer gut wenn
man ein paar vorräte zu hause hat das
empfiehlt auch der empfiehlt auch der
zivilschutz dass man immer noch eine
dose zu hause hat also dass man also
über eine woche mal in wien kommt aber
dafür muss man jetzt dich haben es dann
bis kroner ist kein krieg mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren